Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
guten Morgen Markus so und bevor du mich
jetzt fragst was mir durch den Kopf geht
möchte ich mal wieder wissen was dir
durch den Kopf geht
tatsächlich
im Moment viel Richard ich ich glaube
ich habe dir das nicht erzählt ne ich
war in der Ukraine noch einmal nur für
ein paar Stunden in der
Westukraine und ich muss ehrlich zugeben
ich habe das selten aber ich habe
seitdem Bilder die auch nachts so durch
meinen Kopf wandern und wabern und die
gehen da irgendwie nicht mehr raus ich
sehe die ganze Zeit diese Gesichter ich
sehe diese ausgemärgelten Körper ich
sehe dieses ganze Setting diese diese
Umgebung ich sehe Bilder in schwarz-weiß
von Menschen die mich an Szenen und
Situationen erinnern die wir mit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg mit dem Ersten
Weltkrieg sogar verbinden ich war ums
kurz zu sagen in der Westukraine
irgendwo Ort ist geheim und an dem Punkt
jetzt auch egal in einem
riesengefängnis ind dem die allermeisten
russischen Kriegsgefangenen
untergebracht sind die Ukraine die dort
unter also das größte von von vielen
Kriegsgefangenen Gefängnissen nicht
viele ich glaube ich glaube es gibt
dieses eine sehr sehr große und dann
gibt's bestimmt noch ein paar kleinere
mit Sicherheit und dann gibt's bestimmt
auch noch Orte an denen besonders
schlimme Kriegsverbrecher untergebracht
werden und es gibt gemischte Gefängnisse
ne es gibt Gefängnisse wo normale
kriminelle oder Schwerverbrecher
zusammen mit
Kriegsgefangenen sind das kann ich mir
vorstellen weil ähm
das Thema immer größer wird in der
Ukraine mit dem Fortgang dieses Krieges
ja das hat auch damit zu tun und
deswegen kamen wir auch darauf die
Russen tauschen seit Monaten keine
Gefangenen mehr aus und da gibt es eine
riesige Verzweiflung in der Ukraine ich
ich habe ich glaube im September war es
da haben wir in Kiev in in einem
besonderen Department des
Verteidigungsministeriums gedreht dort
mit dem zuständigen Verantwortlichen
zunächst mal gesprochen äh Petro heißt
der ein interessanter Mann weil da steht
jemand in Uniform vor dir und du
erwartest sozusagen jetzt einen Militär
und dann merkst Du plötzlich so wie der
formuliert wie der ist das ist
eigentlich kein Militär und du erlebst
dann das was du bei Besuchen in der
Ukraine so häufig erlebst du siehst
Menschen in Uniform und merkst plötzlich
ach so warte mal die sind ja in diesem
Krieg hinein gezwungen worden aber da
war natürlich vorher ein ganz anderes
Leben sind alles keine Berufssoldaten or
ganz andere Dinge getan Petro war
Schriftsteller ein ein prämierter
Buchautor ein ein Feingeist wenn du so
willst der jetzt die sehr sehr schwere
Aufgabe hat mehrere Dinge zu tun das
eine ist er muss versuchen diesen diesen
ab und zu mal ein Gefangenen Austausch
zu organisieren die tun sich wahnsinnig
schwer Information darüber zu kriegen wo
ihre Leute sind die versuchen teilweise
auch russische Kriegsgefangene gegen
tote Ukrainer einzutauschen
die versuchen einfach nur eine
gesicherte Information zu kriegen ob der
Mann Männer sind ja meistens überhaupt
noch am Leben ist oder was irgendwie aus
ihm geworden ist und erfahren auch das
meistens nicht und dann gibt es eine
Zusammenkunft regelmäßig und da waren
wir auch dabei da haben wir auch gedreht
und diese diese Bilder dieser Frauen ich
habe das auch mit der Kamera
festgehalten und die sind auch zu sehen
da in dieser Reportage
die auch das sind Gesichter die dir
diese leeren Gesichter diese leeren
Blicke die dir nicht mehr aus dem Kopf
gehen da s sitzen diese Frauen die alle
die große Frage im Kopf haben was ist
aus meinem Mann aus meinem Bruder aus
meinem Lebensgefährten aus dem Vater
meiner Kinder geworden die treffen sich
dann da und Petro sagte mir und das
siehst Du auch im Film die Szene sag
weißt du wir wir geben den Leuten dann
zum Teil den Frauen eine dna-pe und
sagen pass auf wir haben ein DNA-Test
wir wissen dann Mann ist tot und dann
sitzt sie da und sagt können wir das
bitte noch mal machen könnt ihr noch mal
ich will ganz sicher sein das heißt mit
anderen Worten sie wollen es nicht
glauben und natürlich gibt es beim
zweiten und beim dritten Mal auch kein
anderes Ergebnis das ist sehr traurig
und die die die wissen dass ihre Männer
in die kommen zum Teil in schlimmster
Verfassung aus russischer
Kriegsgefangenschaft zurück wenn sie
denn überhaupt zurückkommen irgendwo
hinterm Ural irgendwo nach Sibirien
verschleppt und so weiter und die die
kommen zum Teil zurück als als halbe
Skelette mit mit mit 40 45 50 kg mit mit
schwer Folterspuren und so weiter die
werden systematisch
geschlagen und und gefoltert und
misshandelt und so weiter werden
schlimme Dinge gemacht den Russen ist
das so ziemlich egal und es es gibt
diesen russischen Journalisten akadi
babchenko der in dem Zusammenhang mal
gesagt hat
nachdem er selber an der Front gewesen
war eins ist ganz sicher deine Heimat
Russland wird dich immer im Stich lassen
mein Sohn immer und genau das ist das
Gefühl dass viele Russen auch dort haben
und das ist auch das Gefühl dass die
Ukrainer haben und die müssen jetzt
irgendwie versuchen diesen diesen diesen
Gefangenen Austausch zu organisieren und
das ist der Grund deswegen hole ich auch
soweit aus warum die mittlerweile
regelmäßig internationale
journalistenams in dieses große
Kriegsgefangenen lagager das eigentlich
ein Gefängnis ist ja es ein ein richtig
harter knass wie viele wie
viele Kriegsgefangene sind in diesem
Gefängnis das ist auch interessant das
ist die einzige Frage die Du nicht
stellen darfst du kriegst keine Antwort
darauf aber ich habe die Männer gesehen
ich hab die auch fotografiert allein die
die wir gesehen haben das waren also ich
schätze tausende und ähm mir wurde das
klar in der Situation in der Kantine ähm
du musst dir vorstellen du gehst in
dieses Gefängnis rein du wirst an einen
Ort gebracht irgendwo in der Westukraine
äh leviv ist nicht ganz weit weg davon
um es mal so ein bisschen geographisch
einzuordnen
und dann bringen die da ab und zu
Journalisten da rein ich kannte die
Geschichte weil auch ein Spiegel tvteam
dort schon mal war und so weiter das
Handelsblatt meine ich hte mal darüber
berichtet und die NZZ richtig genau
genau und große Reportage gemacht jetzt
mal das Motiv also die Ukraine zeigt
dieses Kriegsgefangenen
Gefängnis ausgewählten westlichen
Journalisten warum tut man das der Grund
ist einfach und in Wahrheit verstößt das
auch an ein bisschen gegen die Genfer
Konvention ne Artikel 13 ne
Kriegsgefangene über die Behandlung von
kriegsgefang richtig sollten auch nicht
sozusagen entlich neug preisegeben
prisgegeben werden genau so ist die
Formulierung und das kann man auch
durchaus so sehen es ist völlig klar wir
werden da als als Journalisten werden
wir da zum Teil des Spiels der der
Propaganda wenn du so willst das ist gar
keine Frage und das da sollte man auch
nicht drum rum reden das muss man sich
klar machen ich
verstehe trotzdem die Motivation der
Ukraine die Ukraine sagt wir müssen
irgendwie Druck aufbauen wir müssen
Öffentlichkeit herstellen wir müssen
irgendwie versuchen da wieder Bewegung
reinzukriegen da ist eine groß
Gefangenen Austausch wieder aufgenommen
wird genau das ist das Motiv und das
zweite ist was was du dann natürlich
auch verstehst man könnte sagen gut wenn
man kontrollieren will ob es den gut
geht gut ist ein großes Wort in dem
Zusammenhang aber ob die Leute
einigermaßen gut versorgt sind mit ess
mit medizinischer Versorgung und so
weiter äh dann kann man das ja auch wei
ich man kann das Amnesty machen lassen
man kann das andere Staaten machen
lassen man kann das Staatsanwälte machen
lassen ne man kann das die UN machen
lassen und so weiter aber es ist
natürlich schon sag mal auch für die
Ukraine baut sich da auch ein Druck auf
du du kannst dich nicht trauen
internationale Presse in einen
Kriegsgefangenen Lager zu lassen wenn du
die Leute nicht einigermaßen vernünftig
behandelst und es ist interessant weil
du dann anfängst über die
Begrifflichkeit nachzudenken ne wir
hören
Kriegsgefangene eigentlich ist der
Begriff Kriegsgefangene völlig
irreführend an dem Punkt das sind Leute
die sind ein Pfand und das ist ein
wesentlicher Unterschied weil wenn du
wenn du ein Gefangener bist wenn du ein
verurteilter Mörder bist ja wirst nicht
ausgetauscht Nerv na vor allen Dingen du
hast dann eine Uhr vom ersten Tag an
tickt die Uhr und egal wie lange es
dauert aber morgen ist schon wieder ein
Tag weniger ja das ist die Hoffnung an
der Strohhalm an denen die sich klammern
und dieser entscheidende wie ich finde
wirklich psychologisch unendlich
wichtige wertvolle Strohalm den haben
die nicht das heißt auf die
Kriegsgefangenen wartet kein Prozess da
also auf die Kriegsverbrecher definitiv
aber ich glaube die sind normalen
gefangenen Soldaten wartet keinen
Prozess sondern ihr gebt uns Leute und
dann geht das kannst du ja auch in
Israel gerade wiedershen ne Hamas und so
weiter und dann wie kriegen wir unsere
Geiseln daraus und was müssen wir denen
dann im Gegenzug geben und da WD teils
echt genau das sind schwierige
Entscheidungen weil du genau weißt wen
du dann da freiässt jetzt sagst du dass
die Russen
seit einiger Zeit halbes Jahr oder was
hast du gesagt kein kein kriegsgefangen
oder einige
Monate jetzt kein Kriegsgefangenen
Austausch mehr machen was glaubst Du ist
der Grund ist der Grund dass man aus
russischer Perspektive denkt dass man
die Moral in der Ukraine damit
schmällert ja wenn die die Gefangenen
nicht zurückkommen also die Verzweiflung
wächst wogegen man umgekehrt
offensichtlich ja keine Angst davor hat
dass das gleiche in Russland passiert
genau da da haben wir da haben die wenig
Skrupel wenn du die Leute siehst dann
verstehst du auch warum aber natürlich
ist das der Grund diese ukrainische
Gesellschaft zu zu destabilisieren das
sagt Petro auch in diesem Gespräch man
will die Moral der Ukraine einfach
brechen und die brechen sie damit auch
ne das sind es ist wirklich TR traurig
und tragisch das mit anzusehen wie
verzweif die Leute sind und es ist ähm
umgekehrt auch und und da merkst du dann
wie schnell du in diesem ganzen
Spinnennetz aus Lügen und aus
Manipulation wie schnell du da drin bist
wei du von außen sieht das so aus okay
die Sache ist sehr klar da gibt es
dieses dieses Gefängnis das ich ich ich
habe ein ein ein düsteres Foto gemacht
als ich da raus bin da da da siehst du
in dieser dieser diesem Halbdunkel
äh schon fast Nacht und diese diese
alten
Sowjet Straßenlaternen
postsozialistischen Straßenlaternen
leuchten da so vor sich hin und im
Lichtschein einer dieser Laternen steht
so ein alter weißer Lader und dahinter
baut sich dieses Gefängnis auf diese
diese weiße Mauer ja mit zum Teil so
halb verrottet das erinnert ein bisschen
an das was du in Kuba auch siehst ja so
sowas sowas morbides morbides ja
wirklich morbide
und dann dann geht der
eine gefäng werter geht dann da packt
seine Tasche und geht nach Hause und
läuft über diese einsame Straße da
vorbei einfach so ins Nichts und
verschwindet in der
Dunkelheit man man man kriegt das und
deswegen geht mir das auch so so schwer
aus dem Kopf du kriegst das nicht
zusammen dass das Europa 203 sein soll
letzten Endes wenige Autostunden von von
von von Polen von Krakau von Warschau
entfernt und so weiter und trotzdem ist
es eine völlig andere Welt ist wirklich
die Zeit stehen geblieben und du mm du
gehst von außen da rein und viele
Sicherheitsschleusen viele Auflagen und
so weiter vor allen Dingen die Auflage
wenn wenn Leute nicht mit euch reden
wollen dann respektiert das dann redet
auch nicht mit ihnen macht keine
Interviews fotografiert sie auch nicht
und so weiter und natürlich haben uns
daran gehalten wie war denn das also
gab's mehr Leute die mit euch reden
wollten oder welche die sogar ein
richtiges Redebedürfnis hatten oder
wollt ihr die große Mehrheit mit euch
nicht reden das war interessant du du
deswegen meine ich du bist dann ganz
schnell also von außen ist die Sache
eigentlich relativ klar du denkst
triffst jetzt diese Leute und dann bist
du plötzlich drin mittendrin in diesem
spinnnetz aus aus Lügen aus Manipulation
aus Halbwahrheiten aus dreiviertel
Wahrheiten also die haben ja auch
ihrerseits das Problem die Ukrainer
sagen den Pass auf wann du nach Hause
kommst nach Sibirien kann ich dir nicht
sagen weil deine Russen tauschen
niemanden
aus stimmt das was der
ukrainische beauftragte den erzählt oder
stimmt das nicht ist das Propaganda ist
das eine Lüge was sollen diese Leute
glauben GLB die glauben gar nichts mehr
oder so und diese diese diese
Unsicherheit macht die fertig und dann
und dann kommst du rein auch in diese in
diese Welt die eine wirklich harte Welt
ist und du verstehst eine Sache sofort
es geht darin mehr als um alles andere
geht es um Demütigung es geht um
Demütigung und das siehst Du an der
Körperhaltung an der Körpersprache du
siehst diese Männer diesen dunklen
Anzügen mit diesen kurzgeschorenen haen
die haben so so dunkel dunkelblaue Kluft
an ja ja ja ja so wirklich so wie du dir
das vorstellst und dann so schwarze
Mützen auf war kalt kalt nass feucht und
dann die der Kopf prinzipiell gesenkt
die Arme auf dem Rücken es geht um
Demütigung und dann und dann verständ
also das ist die Haltung die die darin
annehmen müssen ja also das ich ich
glaube es wird den sehr schnell
vermittelt dass das genauso erwünscht
ist ja also wenn jemand zu
körpersprachlich zu Domin auftritt dann
muss er mit allem das ist glaube ich
nicht gut das ist glaube ich nicht gut
für ih ja genau und das andere ist dann
und viele psychologische kleine Tricks
dann kommst du rein dann stehst du in in
so in soem in in soem
langen ja in so einer in so einer Flucht
links und rechts hohe Mauern
Stacheldraht und so weiter und dann
stehen die da und links auf der Wand
hast du Bilder von ukrainischer
Geschichte rechts an der Wand hast du
Bilder von großen ukrainischen Sportlern
beispielsweise da hängen auch die beiden
Klit häen vit und Wladimir klitchko mit
Box
weltmeisterschaftsgürteln also als
Poster ja als als Fotos als große Fotos
und zwar immer um den zu sagen Freunde
pass mal auf nur für den Fall dass ihr
es nicht klar habt die Ukraine ist ein
großes Land nicht nur euer Russland wir
haben eine große eine eigene Geschichte
und das hier ist unsere Geschichte und
wir haben ähnlich wie ihr große Sportler
große Künstler große Sänger und so
weiter und das sind diese Leute schaut
sie euch genau an bis hin zu dem Punkt
dem die dann gehen die in so ein so
geschlossenen rein alles alles alles wie
wirklich im Stechschritt gehen die dann
rein in diesen in diesen
Essensraum und dann dann wird wortlos
wird sich erst die Hände gewaschen dann
ran Essen fürchterliches Essen wird von
den Leuten dort selber gekocht man kann
das Essen und mir wurde immer wieder
auch gesagt glaub mir das ist für einen
einfachen Russen ein fantastisches Essen
konnt mir das nicht vorstellen völlig
verkochte Nudeln und so weiter ein
bisschen Borsch gab's so so eine kleine
Bulette eine kleine fleischanlage und du
sahst wirklich für diese Leute dieses
dieses trockene Brot und dieses diesen
dieses bisschen Pasta und und Fleisch
und B dieen das regelrecht verschlungen
in einer atememberaubenden
Geschwindigkeit und dann sitzt man ruhig
an diesen Tischen und dann werden die
Tische wieder rausgerufen ein nach dem
anderen dann stehen die auf wortlos und
dann kommt so ein Reim indem sie sich
bei der Ukraine für das gute Essen
bedanken müssen das wird dann ausgerufen
und dann geht's wieder zurück und immer
in dieser Haltung ja Kopf nach unten
Hände auf den Rücken also da geht's
wirklich das verstehst Du auch ganz ganz
schnell es geht darum den Leuten klar
zumachen pass auf hier habt ihr nichts
mehr zu sagen und dann machst du diese
diese Gespräche du triffst die Leute
dann in in in irgendwelchen Werkstätten
zum Teil ja die die ein haben da ein
großen Ziel Gartenmöbel hergestellt das
waren das war ein Bild ich habe Fotos
davon gemacht ein Bild wie wie alcatras
so stelle ich mir alcatras vor wirklich
fin Zeiten in Schwarz-Weiß wirkt das
noch mal düsterer die Sonne kam so rein
und hunderte von diesen Männern da drin
die die gartenstüh so ratternstühle
zusammenschrauben und anem anderen Ort
haben sie dann irendwelche kuvts
gebastelt und so weiter sah irgendwie
auch so absurd auser da sitzen Typen
erkennbar gezeichnet ja vom Leben mit
mit von oben bis unten täoviert
ausgemärgelte Gesichter und Falten dann
so kleine so kleine süße Kuvert ja das
das das das das kontrastiert so hart das
das kriegst du gar nicht zusammen und
dann dann sprichst du die auch an und
viel erstaunlich viele wollen reden weil
auch die ein Interesse daran haben
Öffentlichkeit herzustellen die hoffen
wenn sie irgendwie stattfinden und auch
unser Film wird seinen Weg genau wird
seinen Weg finden über Youtube und so
weiter soweit ich weiß ist YouTube auch
bis heute in Russland auch
zugänglich ne trauen die sich nicht das
einfach abzuschalten weil dann nimmt man
den Leuten sozusagen Freizeit
Beschäftigung und und dann sozusagen das
Signal an die Angehörigen zu Hause was
auf uns gibt es noch ja und so sehe ich
gerade aus und wenn du jetzt wenn du
jetzt mit ihnen redest dann ist ein
Übersetzer natürlich dabei das klar wie
viele wie viel Wachpersonal oder von der
Gefängnisleitung oder so sind dabei
keiner du wirst mit denen alleine
gelassen ja also du musst dir das
vorstellen sind große Räume da müssen ja
werter sein auch die die Aufruhr
verhindern und soind nee das das ist
nicht die Stimmung da das ist nicht die
Stimmung da das sind nee du du spürst
auch diesen chorgeist du merkst auch
diese diese Ablehnung die dir so zum
Teil entgegengebracht wird ne also die
die verstehen ganz genau dass sie hier
jetzt auch benutzt werden und auf der
anderen Seite gibt's dann immer wieder
den der bereit ist dann zu reden und es
gibt auch welche die melden sich auch
und sagen pass auf ich würde gerne mit
dir sprechen und dann gibt's sehr
interessant je nach Situation erfährst
du natürlich eine völlig andere Wahrheit
wenn du mitten in diesem in diesem
Trubel ja zwischen den ratnstühlen die
nebenbei zusammengeklöppelt werden wenn
du da anfängst jemanden zu interviewen
dann hörst du also du kannst kannst sie
alle 100 abklappern hörst du immer die
gleiche Geschichte hast du Zivilisten
umgebracht nein natürlich nicht hast du
tote Zivilisten überhaupt gesehen nein
natürlich nicht was hast du denn dort
gemacht na ja also ich habe eigentlich
im Wesentlichen ein bisschen Gräben
ausgehoben also eigentlich hatten die
alle nur eine Schaufel in der Hand und
nie eine Knarre ja also keiner von denen
hat irgendwas schlimmes verbrochen das
erzählen sie dir dann so wenn du sie
dann alleine sprichst und wir hatten die
Gelegenheit dazu mit zwei Männern der
eine war ein ein war die klassische
[Musik]
Geschichte die ja in Russland so häufig
in diesem Krieg passiert ist
äh ein ein Mann aus dem hinteren
Sibirien ich glaube in der Nähe von blad
wostock sogar der sagte na ja gut der
hatte da diesen Abend und es wurde sehr
viel getrunken und ich nehme an es war
Wodka und sein Freund war da auch dabei
und dann hat man sich erst sehr nett
unterhalten und dann ein bisschen
weniger nett und irgendwann gar nicht
mehr nett und irgendwann war da eine tot
dann einfach umgebracht i sind in Streit
geraten und hat ihn einfach umgelegt so
das hat er auch so erzählt und sagte ja
den eigenen Kameraden nein das war nicht
im Krieg vor dem Krieg ja zu Hause dann
saß der 5 Jahre im im sibirischen
Gefängnis und dann kam dieses
unwiderstehliche Angebot ne äh du gehst
für sechs Monate an die Front und dann
bist du frei und natürlich nimmt er das
an weil er sagt erstens verdiene ich
dort ein Haufen Geld für meine
Verhältnisse in riesen Haufen Geld und
das zweite ist die restlichen 10N Jahre
sitze ich hier nicht mehr in diesem
grauen vollen Knast russische knäe sind
wirklich hart so und dann hat er sich
gemeldet und der sagt ich bin
unglaublich enttäuscht von meinem Land
die haben uns hier die haben uns total
verarscht die Propaganda ist
allumfänglich die Propaganda
funktioniert so die SAG pass auf da gibt
es in der Ostukraine Arme Russen und die
werden von bösen Ukrainern angegriffen
und ihr müsst ihn helfen und genauso
haben sie sie damals ja auch nach
Afghanistan gelogt und genauso machen
Sie es einfach immer und ich ich musste
so sehr an den einen KGB-Mann aus aus
kishina aus Moldawien denken der mir
damals im März wenn du dich erinnerst
gesagt hat weißt du russische Propaganda
ist unvorstellbar primitiv aber sie
funktioniert wie eine Eins und das
verfängt bei den Leuten das hat
funktioniert und äh und danach
lässt das System die Leute einfach
fallen das ist völlig egal das ist eine
du du gehst rein morgens und du wirst
auch so drauf vorbereitet ja man
überlegt sich ja auch durch den durch
die Dreharbeiten
vorher du du fragst Dich immer wieder
woher kommt diese unvorstellbare
russische Gewaltbereitschaft ja diese
diese strukturelle russische Gewalt und
du gehst dann da rein und du weißt
gleich triffst du diese Leute und dann
hörst du Leute links und rechts sagen du
pass auf das sind wirklich Schweine und
dann gehst du abends raus und denkst ja
das sind wirklich arme Schweine genau
das ist das was du denkst und Du merkst
wie sich die Perspektive auf diese Leute
innerhalb weniger Stunden völlig
verschiebt und das ist ehrlich gesagt
und deswegen wollte ich mit dir darüber
reden Richard das eigentlich das was
mich seitdem am meisten beschäftigt
weißt du das Böse ist ganz trivial ja
das sind ganz normale Menschen ganz
normale Männer ja ja Christopher
Browning du erinnerst dich das Hamburger
Polizeibataillon das Frauen Kinder zu
Hause und dann in in Polen die
schlimmsten Dinge anrichten ja D im
Zweiten Weltkrieg das berühmte Buch so
und die große Frage ist woher kommt das
die Antwort ist Ideologie also die Macht
von Ideologie die eine das ist aber die
eine Antwort also die eine Antwort ist
natürlich die den die Leute zu verführen
und Ihnen eine passende Geschichte
aufzutischen die sie glauben aber das
zweite ist
Konformität das ist ja auch das was in
der Geschichte von Christopher Browning
so so so ein de Moral die Leute du bist
Teil der Gruppe Befehl ist Befehl das
was du tust gilt vor von den offiziellen
als ordentlich als richtig als das soll
man tun das ist gut ja und wenn es die
abscheulichsten Verbrechen sind wenn es
für deine Vorgesetzten in Ordnung ist
wenn es für deine Kameraden in Ordnung
ist dann neigen ganz ganz viele Menschen
dazu das in Ordnung zu finden das ist
das äh Harald Welzer der das ja auch
ausführlich untersucht hat ja S
auch und Harald Welzer haben dieses
ergreifende Buch Soldaten geschrieben
hast das mal gelesen ich habe das nicht
nur gelesen das steht ja sogar 80 cm von
mir entfernt gerade im Regal weil ich
gerade auf auf diese diese Höhe meiner
Bücher gucke das kann man kaum lesen so
gruselig ist das das beruht also auf
Abhörprotokollen von Kriegsgefangenen
whrmachtssoldaten genau die
Kriegsgefangenschaft abgehört wurden das
aber nicht wussten und die sich da so
mit größter Selbstverständlichkeit äh
den brutalsten Taten rühmen ja und da so
alltäglich drüber reden und drüber
lachen keine Reue kein Schuldbewusstsein
und nichts dieses Buch zeigt halt wie
Menschen im Krieg verrohen und zwar
einerseits wie du ja richtig sagst durch
Ideologie ne waren viele waren Rassisten
aber selbst diejenigen die keine Nazis
waren oder keine Rassisten waren haben
wir auch fürchterliche Verbrechen getan
manche waren ja auch nur ganz normale
Zyniker und ganz viele sind durch die
Kriegssituation ja zu Zynikern
Verbrechern und armoralischen Menschen
geworden mm und in der Kriegssituation
selber war das was sie taten ja in
Ordnung das war ja sozusagen
vorgeschrieben so sollte man ja sein der
deutsche Soldat sollte ja diese diese
ganzen kriegerischen Handlungen und
diese ganzen Verbrechen und alles das
Begehen und wenn es in Ordnung ist dann
ist es in Ordnung und das war das was
ich in den Köpfen dieser Menschen fest
gesetzt hat und das ist das worüber wir
heute unsere Köpfe schütteln und uns
überhaupt nicht vorstellen können wie
ganz normale Menschen in
Kriegssituationen zu völlig amoralischen
Menschen ja und Harald Welzer der ja
sagt Menschen sind seiner festen
Überzeugung nach grundsätzlich zu
absolut allem fähig man denkt immer nein
glaube ich im Leben nicht glaube ich
nicht ja aber wir können uns die
Situation nehben nicht vorstellen nicht
nicht unter komfortablen Lebens
Situation ja aber in extremst Situation
ja das ist ja das ist dieser Mechanismus
des Krieges ähm es gibt da ja auch viele
Untersuchungen dazu einen Menschen zu
töten fällt den aller allermeisten
Menschen Gott sei Dank schwer ja das ist
einin biologisch schon schwer es ist
es gibt die ventromediale Region des
Schläfenlappens das ist sowas wie die
wie die zentrale unserer
moralverarbeitung unsere Entscheidungen
getroffen werden im Gehirn und da gibt
es so Dr wie eine sinnlich affektive
Tötungshemmung es fällt Menschen schwer
andere Menschen zu töten und je
unmittelbarer umso mehr also jemand zu
erwirgen ist 100 mal schwieriger als auf
de Knopf zu drücken und jemand ist weg
und erschießen macht die Sache auch
schon leichter je abstrakter das Töten
ne mit einer Drohne ne das fällt vielen
Menschen nicht schwer aber jemanden zu
erstechen oder zu erwürgen oder sowas
fällt den meisten Menschen schwer aber
das ist das grausige beim ersten Mal
exakt wenn man das HT mal gemacht hat
dann ist das nicht mehr wie beim ersten
Mal dann setzt dieser fürchterliche
abscheuliche verrohungsmechanismus ein
Ja und im Krieg wenn man wenn man weiß
der andere bringt dich auch um fühlst du
dich ja auch moralisch legitimiert es
muss irgendwann gar nicht mehr um dein
Vaterland gehen oder soas geht einfach
auch darum entweder der oder ich mhm ja
und dann kommt diese kommt diese diese
achaische Moral die an die Stelle all
deiner feinen und sensiblen
moralempfindungen tritt ja es ist
richtig ich meine weil du das das Buch
gerade zitierst ne Soldaten Protokolle
vom Kämpfen töten und sterben heißt das
glaube ich in in ganzer Länge äh 150.000
Seiten lagen da am Ende vor von Briten
und Amerikanern in speziellen
Einrichtung an abführprotokollen genau
und ich fand es interessant mir war das
ich hatte immer wieder weil ske nel ist
regelmäßig bei uns zu Gast jetzt gerade
auch im Kontext des
ukrainekriegeste
Militärhistoriker genau der zufällig auf
diesen Fund stoßen ist ne der der saß
glaube ich im im Lesesaal des des
Nationalarchivs in London und hat dann
plötzlich gesehen ach da gibt es nicht
nur die offiziellen Verhörprotokolle
sondern gibt es eben diese heimlich
aufgenommenen Mitschnitte und da hast du
dann vom vom oberleuttern bis hin zum
zum einfachen Gefreiten alles drin und
es gibt da so ein paar Zitate wo z.B so
ein Oberleutnant der Luftwaffe am 17
Juli 1940 sagt es ist mir ein Bedürfnis
geworden überlegt dir das mal Bomben zu
werfen das prickelt einem ordentlich das
ist ein feines Gefühl das ist ebenso
schön wie einen
abzuschießen das sagt ein Mensch der
wahrscheinlich in in Deutschland ein
ganz normales bürgerliches Leben gelebt
hat und der das war was man einen einen
anständigen deutschen nannte ich hatte
das Gefühl auch in den Gesprächen mit
diesen
Männern wenn du einmal über diese Grenze
gegangen bist gibt's kein Zurück mehr
bist du eine verlorene Seele ja und du
du du will willst auch über diese Grenze
nicht mehr zurück und der zweite Teil
den Du dann immer mitdenken musst ist
diese Leute kommen irgendwann wieder in
eine ganz normale Zivilgesellschaft
zurück ja wen lässt du da auf die
Zivilgesellschaft los weil diese Leute
wollen im Kopf nicht mehr zurück und es
gibt da ein anderes Protokoll wo einer
sagt erst Kön im Kopf nicht mehr zurück
Markus da ist eine Taste eingerastet die
kannst du nicht wieder lösen Ex ja ist
bessere Formulierung ja ja
es gibt einen Satz auch aus diesen
Protokollen wo einer sagt am ersten Tag
ist es mir furchtbar vorgekommen da habe
ich gesagt Scheiße Befehl ist Befehl am
zweiten und dritten Tag habe ich gesagt
ist ja scheißegal und am vierten Tag
hatte ich meine Freude daran ja das ist
irre oder oder der eine der ein
Jagdflieger Jagdflieger Fischer in
fkstor haben wir einmal dem Bahnhof
angegriffen gerade einen großen
Personenzug am ausfahren und zack die
Bombe rein in den Zug junge Junge und
danach in Klammern schallendes Gelächter
unvorstellbar ja ja ich
m trotzdem noch mal die Frage Richard
also auch aus philosophischer Sicht
jemand der sich auch so viel mit
Sozialpsychologie beschäftigt wie du
meine in keinem anderen Krieg der
Geschichte haben glaube ich Menschen in
einem solchen Ausmaß gemordet wie
während des Vernichtungskrieges gegen
die Sowjetunion ja und die Frage ist
trotzdem immer noch wie waren diese
Gewalttaten möglich warum ist dieser ja
dieser Firnis der Zivilisation sagt man
immer warum ist der so dünn mhm ja es
ist offensichtlich so ne also das ist
all die zivilisierten und kulturellen
Eigenschaften des Menschen gedeihen nur
unter bestimmten Umweltbedingungen mhm
dass man genug zu essen hat dass man in
relativen Wohlstand lebt dass eine
funktionierende Zivilgesellschaft da ist
und so weiter und wir machen uns das ja
im Alltag eigentlich kaum bewusst zu
sehen wie schnell das wieder
verschwinden kann also wie schnell das
was uns völlig selbstverständlich ist
Gott sei Dank ja völlig
selbstverständlich ist was unser Denken
Handeln und Fühlen bestimmt wie schnell
das eingerissen werden kann ich meine
überlegt dir mal
Jugoslawienkrieg ja wie innerhalb ganz
ganz kurzer Zeit die totale Barbarei
ausgebrochen ist Nachbarn sich Wechsel
seitig umgebracht haben ja plötzlich
also Bosnier gegen Serben und Serben
gegen Kroaten und so weiter
wie schnell das auf einmal ging in einem
hochzivilisierten Land wie es
jugoslawien war ja plötzlich ganz ganz
archaische Dinge passieren und das ist
glaube ich eine ganz gefährliche Warnung
dass man dass man den Frieden nie
überschätzen darf und dass man die die
sozialen Qualitäten einer Gesellschaft
nie als selbstverständlich nehmen darf
und vor allen Dingen auch immer mal
drauf gucken muss was man alles hat was
wirklich gut funktioniertm wenn es so ig
dazu nur Bedarf dass alles nicht mehr
funktioniertm ser interessant Harald
Welzer weißt ja auch in in in einem
Gespräch darauf hin dass es natürlich
Leute gibt die das nicht mitmachen
wollen und sagt dann aber das ist aber
dennoch keine einfache keine triviale
Sache weil wenn du nicht mitmachst
dieser bei diesem Gruppenzwang ja der
daraus entsteht dann resultiert daraus
natürlich unmittelbar die nächste Frage
wenn du an der Front bist und du
weigerst dich bestimmte Dinge zu tun
hilft der dir der dann neben mir ist
noch wenn du der nächste bist der
verwundet in der Ecke liegt und stark
blutend und und daruf angewiesen ist von
dem dann Hilfe zu bekommen hilft er dir
dann noch ne also sozusagen die Sorge um
die eigene das eigene nackte Überleben
führt natürlich auch dazu dass du sagst
okay dann bin ich aber im Sinne der
Gruppe damit die anderen mich nicht so
als Störenfried wahrnehmen und so weiter
und als ein der absolut loyal zu Ihnen
steht bin ich natürlich dann mach alle
Augen zu aber bin dann auch bei bereit
bestimmte Dinge zu tun das ist schon
sehr interessant oder wenn du dir z.B
anschaust
äh äh
desertieren ich hab mich ein Interview
von Michael Wolfson ja dem dem
Historiker gelesen der kürzlich bei uns
in der Sendung war sehr sehr kluger
interessanter Mann der immer wieder sich
so eine ganz eigene Perspektive auf
Dinge auch leistet und der sagt weißt du
desertieren ist immer so eine Sache es
gibt die Makroebene und es gibt die
Mikroebene ja auf auf einer Makroebene
mag es äh ja auf der auf der großen
Ebene mag es gut sein mag es eine gute
Sache sein zu desertieren wenn dannin
oberbefeh fitler heißt genau so aber auf
einer Mikroebene mag das trotzdem falsch
sein und das fand ich interessant diesen
Gedanken weil er sagt WN du deine
Kameraden im Stich exakt das ist das
Ding Leute die dich möglicherweise auch
brauchen ist übrigens der Grund warum
viele ne die in einem Krieg gar nicht
hinter der Sache stehen die also auch
für die Propaganda und für die Ideologie
gar nicht empfänglich sind mm mm
trotzdem bei der Fahne bleiben richtig
ja weil man vielleicht auch beste
Kumpels und Freunde dabei hat und weil
man auch von denen nicht im Stich
gelassen werden will wenn man sich bei
der Nachtwache davon schleicht oder was
auch immer ja in Lebensgefahr bringt
richtig ja das sind das sind
das ist ja irre ich meine es gab so
einen Spruch in der in der
friedensbewegungszeit ja also kennst ja
diesen diesen Spruch stell dir vor es
ist Krieg und keiner geht hin ke geht
hin ja ja genau ja und es gab auch den
Spruch die wahren Helden der Kriege sind
die Deserteure ja weil dahinter die
Vorstellung geht WN alle desertieren
gibt's keinen Krieg genau das mag auf
der Makroebene die eine oder andere
Berechtigung haben über die man jetzt
lange kontrovers diskutieren würde ne
wolfsohn würde das sicher ganz anders
sehen aber auf der Mikroebene ne ist
natürlich desertieren immer ein riesiges
Problem richtig ja und es ist ein das
große Problem gegenüber den Kameraden
und das macht die Sache natürlich
unglaublich schwierig betrachte ich den
Menschen als diesen einzelnen Fall
betrachte ich ihn als teil eine Armee ne
man freut sich über jeden Soldaten der
aus Putins Armee äh desertiert ja wenn
er aus der Ukraine desertiert sehen wir
das schon wieder mit anderen Augen die
Frage ist auf welcher Seite man dann
steht aber das individuelle Schicksal
das nähert die beiden Soldaten wieder
enorm aneinander an ja beide wollen
nicht ihr Leben in diesem Krieg
verlieren und da sind sie sich auf
einmal völlig gleich ganz egal für
welche Armee sie kämpfen mhm ja es ist
es ist auch ähm
wenn man mal zurückschaut es gab
erinnerst du dich an den Fall B bergdal
das ist ein eine Geschichte die 2014
spielt der letzte US-Soldat der aus der
Taliban Gefangenschaft befreit wurde
barack Obama ist
Präsident und der der zeigt wie kurz der
Weg sozusagen vom Helden zum Verräter
sein
kann Obama sagt wir haben den jetzt
rausgeholt das ist ein ein ein eine
große Freude die ganze Nation teilt
diese Freude und so weiter und dann
kommt wenig später raus der war
desertiert der war jemand der abwesend
war ja absent without leave sozusagen
der der der der war weg und dann schlägt
die Freude über die Befreiung dieses
jungen Mannes komplett um ja in in Hass
und so weiter am schärfsten natürlich
bei den bei den harten Rechten in
Amerika und so weiter und Donald Trump
dreckigen dreckigen miesen Verräter ja
und dieser Bergtal hat hinterher erzählt
er ist nach Afghanistan gegangen weil er
Jason bourn sein wollte so ein richtiger
Draufgänger also und die triffst du da
übgens auch ja die habe ich dort auch
getroffen Männer siehst du den auch an
und wenn du dann merkst wie sie mit dir
reden das sind einfach so Draufgänger
die haben wenig zu verlieren und die
wollten jetzt mal wirklich was erleben
die haben auch glaube ich vorher zum
Teil schon schlimme Dinge getan aber
viele halt eben auch nicht nur das ist
sehr interessant wie dann wie dann
plötzlich ja die große
kriegsheldengeschichte die kippt
komplett und plötzlich hast du den den
miesen Verräter da und alle fallen über
den her er hat's dann hinterher versucht
zu erklären und sagte da gibt's
führungsversagen bei den Vorgesetzten
und so weiter äh aber ich
ähm glaube dann entsteht Hal kann ja
auch sein das kann ja auch sein weiß ja
nicht welche Einheit er war unter
welchen Bedingungen warum er weggegangen
ist vielleicht war es auch einfach nur
Angst vielleicht war es auch einfach nur
Angst und es ist völlig okay in so eine
Situation Angst zu haben ich erinnere
mich an an einen den wir da gesprochen
haben der ist auch in dem Film
äh das hat mich wirklich bewegt wir
zeigen die Szene nicht wo er am am
Telefon die die die dürfen regelmäßig
stehen dann auf so einem Flur und warten
dort dürfen regelmäßig nach Hause
telefonieren wer auch interessanterweise
von ihren russischen Familien nicht
großartig in irgendeiner Form mal
besucht oder so die würden sogar das
möglich machen die wollen aber
eigentlich nur wissen dass es denen gut
geht und sagen dir bleib mal wo du bist
die eigenen Familien sagen den häufig
pass auf bleib wo du bist in der Ukraine
bist du sicherer als bei uns zu Hause
das ist auch hart erzählt viel über ein
Land und dieser Mann
auch aus Sibirien der war
ähm unter Umständen die man sich
irgendwie gar nicht vorstellen kann
wirklich miese Propaganda ein ein
Geflecht aus Lügen und Verirrungen und
Verwirrungen in diesen Krieg reingeraten
es waren Bauarbeiter der wollte in die
Ostukraine den Donbass um dort Häuser zu
bauen weil man dort gutes Geld verdienen
konnte kommt da an kommt in diese
russisch kontrollierten Gebiete und die
nehmen ihm direkt den Pass ab und sagen
du pass auf du kannst deine Häuser bauen
und so weiter aber erstmal müssen wir
jetzt hier ein bisschen Krieg führen und
so wir bilden euch ein wenig aus und
danach
geht ein Leben ganz normal weiter das
heißt der ist reingezwungen worden in
diesen Krieg und was sie dort wirklich
machen hat man den vorher auch nicht
gesagt und es gehört ja bis heute zu den
finde ich zu den zu den verstören Dingen
rund um diesen Krieg das wird auch immer
klarer hab neulich so ein langes Stück
in der NZZ auch dazu gelesen die die
russische Führung die Leute rund um
Putin Putin seinen Kumpel Schoigu der
Verteidigungsminister gerassimof
wahrscheinlich noch der der oberstratege
und so weiter diese Leute wussten was
sie vorhaben der ganze Rest wusste im
Grunde nichts weiß man das eigentlich so
genau ja das weiß man mittlerweile
glaube ich ganz gut woher genau kann ich
dir jetzt auch nicht beantworten aber ja
weil ich meine das ist ja nicht einfach
zu wissen ne also da müssen ja Leute aus
dem aus dem Inner Circle erzählt haben
dass sie nicht eingeweiht gewesen s aber
das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen ja aus
dem inner Inner Circle vermutlich nicht
aber es ist erstaunlich wie wie wie doof
die Leute da gehalten wurden und wenn Du
siehst wie es dann abgelaufen ist
verstehst du das auch und wenn du die
Geschichte dieses Mannes hörst dann
verstehst du es auch das sagt wir hatten
keine Ahnung was wir machen und wir
waren plötzlich an der Front und da
sagte er wir waren er hat auch den das
Wort benutzt sagt wir waren
Kanonenfutter wir wurden wir wurden
einfach in diese Schlacht geschickt und
es war klar kaum einer von euch wird
zurückkommen und die sagen den dann auch
pass auf wenn i nicht zurückkommt dann
ist ist egal dann haben wir die nächsten
und dann stehen dann hinter zum Teil
auch diese diese diese diese diese
Soldaten diese diese Truppen noch aus
stalinszeiten kennt man diese Methode
wer zurückläuft wird erschossen das
heißt du kannst nur nach vorne die
erschießen notfalls auch die eigenen
Leute ja ja das das waren Methoden schon
im Zweiten Weltkrieg ja wenn du wenn du
diesen Mann hörst der sagt dir pass auf
wir waren 200 Mann wir sind da rein und
elf kam zurück stell es mal vor ja 200
rein kommen zurück das das das ist so
das Verhältnis da gerade auch am Anfang
gewesen und der der war fertig der war
der war völlig durch mit seinem Land und
da habe ich auch wieder gedacht es ist
unvorstellbar wie stark Ideologie ist ne
kennst du den sozial Psychologen Solomon
Ash ja selbstverständlich ist einer der
der sozusagen Pioniere der Disziplin so
und der der hat doch berühmten Ash
exerimente genau kannst du das mal
erzählen das ja da geht es darum dass
man bei Linien einschätzen soll wie lang
die sind welche Linie länger und welche
kürzer ist und dann wird man manipulativ
beeinflusst aber aber dieses Experiment
ist schon faszinierend ne ich meine du
hast oben eine Linie die ist die
Referenzlinie dann hast du darunter drei
weitere Linien einees zu kurz eine ist
zu lang und eine passt
und du musst nur sagen okay pass auf
diese Linie passt genau auf die andere
drauf und dann machen die das alle und
sagen ja das passt und dann setzt du
Einflüsterer plötzlich dazu und machst
die Leute systematisch wuschig quasi
Propaganda und sagst du nee überleg noch
mal ist die wirklich und könnte es nicht
eher die und am Ende sagen
die und ich ich glaube in diesem
Experiment jeder vierte oder so war in
der Lage diesen Einflüsterungen zu
widerstehen der Rest hat aufgegeben
genau hat sich dann dem angepasst und
gedacht na ja gut wenn der das jetzt
schon so sagt und ja und so weiter also
man vertraut dann auf sein eigenes
Urteil oder auf den eigenen Instinkt
nicht nicht mehr genau
aber man denkt es ist dann so
offensichtlich und es gibt eine
interessante Erklärung die ich auch für
komplett plausibel halte eine Begründung
die glaube ich der ein oder andere da
auch geäußert hat und sagt du was auf
ich ich wollte einfach mal R haben
wollte jetzt da kein Ärger haben ich
wollte jetzt einfach raus mal ich z war
unang ganz normale menschliche
Verhaltensweise seine Ruhe haben wollen
kein Ärger haben wollen nicht auffallen
zu wollen nicht anecken zu wollen und
das sind natürlich alle Fähigkeiten die
man beim Militär auch braucht das merkst
Du auch übrigens ne wenn du da bist das
geht ganz hart mit mit befehlung
Gehorsam ja aber das ist jede schlagkräf
operiert
so du warst ja da also ich meine du hast
mir noch nie so genau erzählt aber ich
meine du wärst beim italienischen
Militär
gewesen ich ich äh so so diese das was
da sozusagen dieser strukturelle Teil
von Demütigung ist ne was man auch immer
über die russische Armee hört der der
die die die diese
großväterkultur ja also dann dann wird
in den Stiefel gepisst und dann musst du
aus diesem Stiefel trinken und so weiter
und sofort Leute werden zum Teil zu Tode
geprügelt also junge Rekruten und so
äh oder oder oder müssen dann irgendwie
weiß ich Schuhcreme auf auf ihr
Butterbrot schmieren und dann essen und
so all solche Dinge diese Art von
Demütigung die gibt es ja in in der
russischen Armee bis heute und
wohlhabende Familien kaufen deswegen
auch ihre Söhne vom Armeedienst einfach
raus weil sie möchten dass Sie dass sie
weiter am Leben bleiben das ist
strukturelle Gewalt aber dieser Begriff
des Großvaters den hast du z.B auch auch
wir hatten das in unserer Einheit den
gab's jeder wusste wer die sogenannten
Noni der nor ist der Großvater und es
war völlig klar der Welt ja also
vielleicht von sehr sehr wenigen
Ausnahmen abgesehen aber das das ist
sowas ich meine das ist ganz
wahrscheinlich schon Malin Römern
gegeben ja also ich glaube das sind
diese diese Strukturen in denen
Hierarchie verinnerlicht wird ja ich
wie gesagt in in in weit schwächerer
Form bin ich fest davon überzeugt gibt
es das in jeder Armee und auch wir haben
das damals dort so erlebt und du merkst
du kommst da rein ne dieses System in so
eine riesige Kaserne wander weiß ich
2000 Leute oder so und und du kommst da
rein und die die Verunsicherung ist ja
unglaublich groß ja da da kommt so ein
einfacher Junge vom Dorf irgendwie und
kommt rein in dieses System fremde Stadt
dann rein in so ein in so ein System da
ist der Wunsch sozusagen nicht
aufzufallen maximal groß du willst nicht
unangenehm auffallen sondern du willst
einfach irgendwie durchkommen irgendwie
mitschwimmen das ist das Gefühl und
deswegen ist dieses System der der non
ja dieser groß Väter dieser dieser
sadistischen Typen das ist natürlich
nicht nur Sadismus sondern das ist schon
auch genauso gewollt weil es natürlich
dazu führt du hoff ich weiß doch dieses
Gefühl der Typ mit dem ich jetzt hier zu
tun habe mein Vorgesetzter der nur noch
drei Monate hat oder so ja das ist dann
der non no und hoffentlich erwische ich
ein netten Typen hoffentlich ist das ein
anständiger Typ deswegen ist einer der
Gründe warum ich so sehr dagegen bin
Berufsarmeen zu haben weil ne wenn du
Glück hast in einer ganz normalen in
einer Bürger in Uniform Idee ja
da kann es sein dass der sogenannte
Nonno der jetzt gerade faul auf der auf
der auf der auf der versifften Decke
rumliegt ja das kann sein dass der
gerade ein Medizinstudium hinter sich
hat ja das ist ein Typ der der der will
in Zukunft Menschen helfen das ist kein
Sadist den du da triffst aber wenn du da
so Leute hast die sonst wenig im Leben
vorhatten und dann einfach als letzten
Ausweg den Weg in die Armee gewählt
haben kannst du dir nie sicher sein es
gibt auch da sehr sehr anständige ganz Z
fest V aus genau Gott sei Dank aber es
gibt auch echt schwierige Kandidaten das
der Punkt sag mal wann wird denn deine
deine Dokumentation ausgestrahlt am
Dienstag
22:45 ja ich glaube gibt ein
eindrückliches Bild davon was dieser
Krieg mit dieser ukrainischen
Zivilgesellschaft macht aber auch wie
sehr er auf so vielen Ebenen
Menschen Zerstörer ihr Leben ja
zerstörerisch ist und einfach
alles kontaminiert und es ist einfach
klar es gibt kein danach mehr das so
ähnlich sein wird wie das vorhers nicht
in den beiden nachfolgenden Jahrzehnten
oder solange diese Generation noch lebt
ja also furchtbar ja okay ich werde es
mir anschauen danke dir Richard wir
hören uns nächste Woche ja mach es gut
und bis bald ja Tschüss
tschüss eine Produktion von hoch 2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF